it's a
breathtaking
moment for me
in the sands of the necropolis bassem
has made an incredible discovery
so what we are looking here is one
fragment
of a mummy portrait that is painted
with the
wax the encaustic technique
greek artists from alexandria travel
south through egypt along the nile
people commissioned their portraits from
the artists
who painted with hot beeswax onto wood
the lifelike portraits were unlike
anything in egyptian art
people hung their colorful portraits in
their homes
when they died the portrait was put on
their face before they were mummified
in the hope their spirit would remember
what they looked like in the afterlife
[Music]
it's really a masterpiece
despite the layers of dust
bassem can clearly make out the face of
the woman it depicts
we can realize all the detail the hairs
eyes
nose lips and even the necklace the
green necklace from emerald and the
tunic the greek tunic which is painted
in purple
it's a beautiful portrait of a greek
woman who lived and died here at
philadelphia around the time of
cleopatra
some 2000 years ago
bassem thinks tomb robbers must have
broken the fragile painting when they
tried to remove it from the grave
when it's broken into small fragments or
slides
for them it's useless they could not
sold it to the market so most probably
they left it at the side for us as a
treasure
i can't see
any kind of object that could be more
beautiful
than this face
it's a great discovery everything bassem
has hoped for
the aim of the mission
we can say that it's accomplished this
single piece makes our work here worth
it
because it's in itself
it's unique
it's possible that cleopatra too would
have been buried with a lifelike
portrait of herself
we know very well
that ancient egyptian
were very keen in keeping the picture of
this deceased it seems that the
tradition continued
during the tulamai period they kept the
same tradition but they did it their own
way using a new tradition of paintings
and then they put this
wonderful amazing awesome portraits on
the face and then they wrapped
the whole mummy in an egyptian style
bassem's discovery suggests that even
outside alexandria the greeks of her
reign followed cleopatra's example
and embraced egyptian customs
and cleopatra's respect for the old ways
won her favor with the egyptians
allowing her to rule over a prosperous
multicultural empire
[Music]
you